لماذا لا يطلق الجيش النار على فلسطينيا
اي يحملوا حجرا وزجاج حارقه حتى دون ان
يلقيها هذا تساؤل لاثمار ابن كثير الزعيم
حزب القوه اليهوديه اليمنيه المتطرف في
اسرائيل تسال يتجه ليصبح واقعا ابنك
فيرتلا حقيبه الامن الداخلي بموجب اتفاق
الائتلافي بين حزب القوه اليهوديه وحزب
الكود ابي رئاسه ابن يمين نتنياهو وصوله
بنتفرج ان يقلقوا الداخل والخارج في
اسرائيل لماذا تاريخ الرجل عنصريه متطرف
هو موقفه الان حساس جدا بصلاحيات واسعه
غير مسبوقه قد تتخطى صلاحيات القاده
العسكريين حتى طموح بن فير ان لن يقف عند
احد شرعانتي وتوسعه المستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه بل سيستثمر في برنامجه الطموح
تشكيل مجموعات مسلحه من ابناء المستعمرات
يمتلك الرجل صلاحيات وميزانيه ماليه تمنحه
ذراعا امنيه ليس داخل اسرائيل فحسب وانما
في الضفه الغربيه ايضا لكن الاخطر تمويل
مشروعه لتحويل قوه مستوطنين الى قوه
المنظمه والعدد يقدر ب 200 الفلاح خطرا
تحسسه بني جانس وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
هاجم صلاحيات الممنوحه لبنك فير لكنه يخشى
السيناريو الاسواق يخشى تشكيله ميليشيا
ايضا انهيار الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه
وبنكير على الراس قوات حرس الحدود في
الامس القريب كان يطالب بقتل من يحمل حجرا
او زجاجه حارقه لكن اليوم خرج في تسريبنا
ان يحذر انصاره منه محاوله التسرع في
تنفيذ اجددته فهل يريد تنفيذها ببطئ يبدو
ذلك احتمالا اقرب فالرجل قدمت ضده ثلاث
وخمسون لائحه اتهام بممارسه العنف او
التحريض عليه بل اودين سابقا بتهمه
العنصريه ودعم الارهاب